You know what's awkward? In college, I
almost failed public speaking. And now,
I make a living as a public speaker. In
this video, I'm going to share the lesson
that I learned from almost failing public
speaking so that you can steal that lesson
and apply it to your own conversations so that
you don't come across as awkward and ideally,
you don't feel awkward as well because
nobody needs that. Let's get into it.
So, fast forward a bit after Dr. Baku's
public speaking class that I almost failed,
I was invited to give a TedEx Talk. And in
the first 30 seconds of that Ted talk and the
2 minutes preceding that ted talk, I would say I
was the most nervous I've ever been in my entire
life choicefully. There's been other times where
I felt like my life was at risk or something and
I've been really nervous but I put myself in
that position and was really really nervous.
And the lesson that I learned from almost failing
public speaking and on how to manage my own nerves
in speaking has made me a way more comfortable,
less awkward conversationalists. I think.
Steven is that true? -That's true. -Alright. So,
in college, I was giving a speech. And the reason
I almost failed the class is I tend to talk
like this with my hands. And it's just the way
that I speak. It's who I am. I can't actually
help it. I'm not trying to do it necessarily.
But Dr. Baku thought that I needed to use my hands
as batons to direct the audience's attention. And
I thought that was stupid. And I refused to put
myself into this baton mode. And I didn't do well
in the class but I didn't fail. And the lesson
that I learned from the fact that a few years
after that was invited to give a TEDx talk and
now make my living as a professional speaker is
if you don't want to be an awkward, period. But if
you don't want to be an awkward in conversation,
let go of any need you have
to be someone that you're not.
Right? I could have tried to do the batons but it
wouldn't have been remotely authentic. And every
second that I'm not being myself or authentic. And
this applies in these videos too. When I make all
these videos for this channel to share and how to
make engagement and connection easy, for me, if
I'm not being totally myself in the video, I don't
think it resonates as well. I think that we value
people who are just transparent that feel like
actual human beings and don't feel like they're
in presentation mode giving you... Right? There's
something that creates a separation. And what
erases awkwardness is a connection. So, if you're
able to connect with somebody, ideally you are
being really yourself and so is the other person.
Now, the TEDx talk that I gave that you can check
out in a link up here was on this idea of taking
positive social risks. And in it, I talked about
this awkward bump or this anxious bump that no
matter what type of social interaction you're in,
I'm not going to say 100% but I'm comfortable
saying 99.8% of conversations and interactions and
relationships at some point have at least a moment
of awkwardness to cross over. And once you've
crossed over that, it's like a rite of passage
of the relationship. And you get to move on and
really connect deeply and that's out of the way.
Very few people meet each other and are just like,
"Ah, we get along so well. There's never
any..." Right? That is a fairy tale. And so,
part of not being awkward in conversation is
recognizing that that awkwardness is actually
your own story and your own label.
You can re-label that awkwardness
as a conversation in progress. And as soon
as you do that, the conversation becomes
changeable and editable. Now, for me, I told you I
was the most nervous I've ever choicefully been a
few minutes before I gave this TEDx talk which is
kind of ironic that I felt so nervous and awkward
before giving a talk about stepping over this
awkward or anxious bump. And my learning with
that was for the first... For the minutes before
and for the first 30 seconds of the talk, I was so
focused on this person. I was so focused on how
people saw me. Were they going to like this video,
were they going to accept and be okay with
the ideas I was sharing? Were they going
to disagree? Were they going to unfriend me on
Facebook? Whatever. We have a desire to be liked.
I have met very few people who don't have a desire
to be liked at some level. And so, that shows up
sometimes, when we feel like we're not being
liked, that shows up as awkwardness. And so, for
me the tool to not be awkward in a conversation
is to flip your perspective and let go of yourself
and what you look like and feel like, etc and
focus on the other person. You will notice that
awkwardness gets deleted right away. I will say
one of my mentors Erik Tyler wrote a book called
the best advice so far. And really brilliant book.
And in one of... It's the best advice so far.
And one of the chapters is on this idea that when
you call something out or when you name something,
half the awkwardness leaves it right away or
half the power leaves it right away. And so,
if you're worried about being awkward in
conversation and the things I shared in the
last couple minutes such like aren't enough
to make you feel less awkward, I would say
call it out. Call out whatever it is that you're
experiencing or whatever that's making it awkward
because typically, not always, but typically half
the awkwardness gets erased right in that moment.
I happened to have put together a book with
my co-author Will Wise on this entire idea of
how to have meaningful conversations. It's called
Ask Powerful Questions: Create Conversations That
Matter. And books cost money so you can get a free
excerpt of it below for zero dollars or Amazon,
I think still sells books along with everything
else in the world. I'm Chad, have an awesome day.